hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now you
may not be able to hear it but if you
listen closely you can hear the screams
of hell from where we are because we're
currently down in the inactive lava zone
or as I have recently discovered the
very active lava zone with a lot of
living creatures and a lot of horrible
monstrosity and we're going to get to
that in just a second
but I wanted to point out I'm currently
running out of space for these lockers
so I know I wanted to build a locker for
every single one of these but I actually
don't have any more titanium and in
order to get some I would have to go
back up to the surface and I'm not going
to waste you guys as times with that so
I'm going to read for names instead of
just a normal three so first up is
Gretchen wenzer who said I'm watching
this to unwind and relieve stress after
taking the a CT today love you mark you
always help me cheer me up so thank you
so much Gretchen for watching I'm really
glad these videos can make you a little
bit happier after some stressful testing
and to follow up that really nice
comment
shorty plays one says mark you need to
try to scan the sea dragon Leviathan
without being attacked like this so he
sees this that is by and far the worst
idea I have ever heard in the history of
subnautica and if you actually want me
to do that you don't care about my
well-being at all okay I'll try my best
for you next up is Dinnerbone who said
mark I'm so proud of you watching the
series I've watched a [ __ ] baby boot
develop into a less [ __ ] man keep up
the good work
thank you for that dinner bone I'd like
to think that I've replaced my [ __ ]
baby nature with a more complainy type
of nature that doesn't actually help
anything while I'm down here but makes
me feel better and last up or galaxy
ghost who says if you hear recurring
chirping inside a powered vehicle that
means you probably have a lava larger
larva
- which I'm not sure if those sounds are
a la ville article but it's also
creatures that I don't want to hear the
weird material in the lava zone is
kyanite you must have had something
bugged with your game because you should
be able to mine that okay so that's good
to know
I don't know what to do about it now
though mm3 next time put a condom on big
box Barry
hey I like to think that's not my job to
personally do that sort of stuff but
I'll have the sex talks with big bucks
Barry and the responsibility he needs to
take as a father from now on so as you
can see oh hey oh the weird creature I
don't know what you are and I don't know
why you're here my lights even on oh
there we go now I can't see anything
still okay but what I need to do before
I go any further in here I know you guys
are dying to see the lava dragon but I
passed the alien research lab I need to
get to that because the story is
paramount for this if I don't do that
and I'm not entirely sure where I am by
the way I'm a little bit lost but I'm
gonna try my best to turn this 180
degrees background and to stick my ass
back through the crevices that I dragged
it through and I'm killing creatures on
the way and just get back Oh what is
that is that a lava ray oh you're
beautiful you're beautiful to me oh boy
I don't like that at all with my luck
I'm going to run smack-dab into the very
center of the dragon and I'm actually
going deeper into this hellhole and not
at all coming out of it and I never will
and I'll never see anybody ever again
oh my hey you gonna so good get wrecked
[ __ ] okay this seems to be generally
kind of upward saamne I'm gonna assume
this is the way I came
well you know what they say about
assumptions they lead you directly into
the mouth of a sea dragon device and the
ones to eat you hold and even if even if
everyone tells you that it can't damage
your big giant Cyclops something tells
me it's still going to try to eat me
dead and I'm going to be dead when I get
eaten but not for a while but until I
pass through its digestive tract then
I'll be dead somewhere in the actual
river not in the lava zone but in the
river there's another alien base that
requires this orange artifact and what
I've been told I haven't looked this up
to confirm this but what I've been told
and the reason I need to find that alien
base is because I need to use my orange
artifact to get in there and then I need
to get another artifact from there to be
able to use it to unlock the lava zone
one and so I can't progress without it
so that's why I have to backtrack and
here is hi okay this isn't the tree but
this is the force where the tree was so
I yeah I will be back when I find it and
trust me I know what I'm doing when it
comes to getting lost so you can account
on me being gone for quite alright quite
a while I'll be right back
mama bomba man this still blows my mind
it's all here I mean I know it shouldn't
charge it the game would even sell I
just can't help but imagine that there's
stuff like this hidden down in our own
ocean because we can only map as far as
radar and sonar will allow us to see the
ground floor what if there's underwater
under under the floor of the ocean cave
systems just like this miles and miles
below penetrating into the crust of the
earth and they're just weird
disturbing life that lives down there
there's a there's a horrifying fun I
don't want to think about it too much
but it's a possibility because we don't
know who knows does anything know the
things that get eaten by those things no
I don't know what's over here it might
be something what is that oh is that it
what is that okay ah well this is
something okay there's definitely
something this looks like precursor but
it looks derelict and crashed and just
kind of and they're not doing so good if
I had to venture a guess
whoa how did I miss this this is just
around the corner the plateau just
before you drop down into the Braintree
thing if you take a corner that's kind
of like off to the side it says it's an
entrance new that is not an entrance
okay so what are we dealing with here is
this the thing that I was looking for
question mark I'm going to assume that
it is my my the gravitational pull feels
weird here
okay so there's got to be a way in I
think my best bit let me crashing into
something or something crashing into me
I don't know which option I want more I
think this might be what I'm looking for
because otherwise I would there be a
giant precursor installation here as
derelict as it might be so I'm no hey
wha Parvati oh okay all right then well
I'm gonna go down there and I'm gonna
see what I can what I can do about this
let me speed up before I go down I've
got my orange artifact on me and I've
got more importantly my Keep Calm Kitty
poster which is definitely going to keep
me brave and calm in the face of sure
death which I think I'm going to find
Wow
things look a lot a lot bigger once
you're out of the Cyclops and actually
on the ground here hoo boy oh man but
jam but what are you I'm just checking
the sides first before I go on the top
or around the bottom just want to be
thorough about this and give a sweeping
search some kind of a skeleton down
there okay that's not that's not
machinery do I'm happy for me being done
here but that's definitely a skeleton of
some sort and we've got just looks like
just a kind of a hole there but not a
way in oh this guy's trapped down here
there must be will to shiny thing was I
saw all right keep movin keep around
sides yeah cuz it's got a lot of damage
I don't know what would have caused this
damage besides like internal power
failure causing explosions and whatnot
but something happened here and it's
whatever it is is not friendly
okay so I've looked pretty much on every
side of this thing it doesn't seem like
there's an entrance right now the big
docking bay that I would have guessed to
be an entrance seems to be closed off so
I'm just going to assume
sorry about that sorry sorry I'm just
gonna assume it all is right in the
world and I can move on with my search
for this thing and this is not what I'm
looking for even though it looks
definitely like what I'm looking for
cuz I checked every sign of that thing
and whoa wait a minute okay maybe I
didn't because holy [ __ ]
uh how did I not see this what the [ __ ]
is that
what is that unfinished textures really
no way how did I miss that number one
I'm just gonna go out I gotta go out in
the suit how did I miss that
okay I almost miss that I was just about
ready to give up holy [ __ ] let me in
there what the [ __ ]
okay I found I then I found what appears
to be an unfinished area it's untextured
and it's kind of here
what the heck is this is that a map is
that what they look like
it's the interpretive art it's graffiti
that's what it is
whoa it's like glowing walls that whoa
what the Frick is that hello what the
hell is that like it is that like an
aquarium in there whoa the inside of
this is an aquarium
what the hell I mean I know this is
unfinished so like none of this has all
of its polish but that's this is that I
mentioned - it should I go in there Oh
some sort of medical Bay where they were
studying something holy [ __ ]
where am i I'm literally in an
observation area inside is this where I
think this is the unfinished place where
the precursor researchers were studying
the the Nazi dragon but to see Emperor
unless this is where the sea dragon was
and in its escape destroyed the facility
which might be totally plausible I have
no idea but it's so weird I mean
obviously this isn't what I'm looking
for this isn't where I use the orange
artifact because this is unfinished now
I know for a fact that the the other one
is part of the main game right now but
this is still fascinating to see Hado no
no no come
don't be ridiculous come on man they're
cute okay so that's that's fascinating
so that's either the place where the sea
dragon Leviathan was held or it's the
place where the sea Emperor will
eventually be held and that's cool that
is crazy cool but either way I think I'm
in the wrong place to get what I need
for this there's a lot of skeletons just
very sensible and I can only assume that
the precursors were exploring this area
and trying to find stuff out about the
the animals who lived here and
something went wrong and they died so
what's so fascinating is there's still
that giant skeleton the humongous
skeleton the enormous skeleton just
laying out in the main area and what the
hell was that - that is a creature that
existed on this planet so in this world
in their prehistoric times
they don't even have written history but
before them came enormous creatures just
enormous creatures housed terrifying
with an entire reality how horrifying
was it all of that I cannot imagine I
don't want to imagine I will I will
nevertheless continue to imagine because
I can't help myself now because that's
buried in my brain but hopefully
hopefully we don't have to meet any of
those creatures in our lifetime maybe
and welcome back welcome back you maybe
sing but where are we now
oh well that's different
anyway there are some changes now
because it's a good thing I actually
looked up before I spent an hour
searching like I did the last time the
alien cache or the precursor cache that
the orange artifact is necessary for
wasn't in the live version of the game
it was in the experimental version so I
saved it's located in a place called the
the ghost Canyon I believe it's called
I'm not 100% sure it's it's in the ghost
Canyon or something to that effect
I'm not 100% and you may notice that
there's some slight differences here one
you got the translucent douchebags
floating around I don't mean to call you
douchebags I'm assuming you're very nice
very nice perfectly normal creatures of
the deep that I don't like very much but
also I'm literally in a place that I
just saved and then loaded up and I
think I see it yes I do
hi smiley Jim oh boy you are terrifying
whoa hey all crap squid that's new Oh No
but anyway so if you go into the ghost
Canyon which is the main place that I
just went to go away
don't even think about it yeah it can't
affect me my Cyclops is nigh
invulnerable all right you do whatever
you feel like but if you go in the ghost
cannon normally you take a right to go
down to the giant skeleton but in the
experimental version right here oh
that's loud right here the entrance to
this weird creature that apparently this
this creature right here was strange
enough that the precursor set up an
entire lab dedicated just to studying
this thing now you know they dedicated
resources to studying things like the
sea dragon Leviathan and I am now stuck
on it which is great
naki moving oh why am I stuck on it hey
come on let me go I gotta move further
down again but I think this will get my
hydration
Oh Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta
Yatta
so I did I did waste quite a bit of time
looking around for this thing I
apologize for that I'm trying to do my
best here let me just pop out the
batteries because I need to switch swap
them over a little bit about buh buh buh
buh these are nice and black charred
have they been burnt by this one
are we not up to full power is it using
them spread evenly in the experimental
version oh hello here you go there you
go there right we should be up to full
ish man I've got a lot of lot of duds
here okay good enough okay
so now that I got bad I'm going to take
mr. Fisher out with me into this place
for as long as I need to use mr. Fisher
oh man that is weird it's like it
reminds me of something from Starcraft
like some of the Zerg things I think
from brood war the thing that shot
little scarabs up know that was the
Protoss I don't know my don't know my
Starcraft anymore but is something
there's ah there it is okay so this
should be the terminal and that means
I'm going to save I'm saving the
experimental version which might ruin my
save and die early I haven't backed it
up but I'm committed to continuing in
the experimental mode because it's where
all the crazy stuff can happen but I'm
gonna save cuz boy howdy am i weird [ __ ]
that bad boy down in there oh yeah I
almost wish it all of my time all right
open up for me
[Music]
what dramatic music you seem to be
playing for some strange reason okay so
there's some kind of bony alien bone
specimen cakes
oh that sounds horrifying already I'll
get a good read of that one oh so they
were just as curious as I was about
these bones only they decided to
actually take him with him and then the
ghost of the horrible monstrosity
followed them and murdered them all okay
these fossils likely came from an
ancient ancestor of the Leviathans which
inhabit the planet today hey that's
that's actually exactly what I guessed
isn't it I'd like to think so anyway Hey
oh so weird map thing again okay fauna
reproductive data whoo I bet that's an
enticing read okay
this terminal contains extensive data on
the reproductive methods of the local
fauna fawn on the planet evolved with a
single gender capable of both egg laying
and insemination eggs once laid usually
require genetic material from a second
individual to reach maturity in rare
cases there is only one true parent with
evolutionary mutation introduced by the
effects of the environment itself on the
delicate genetic structure of the child
researcher appears to have been focused
around hatching conditions and genetic
variations between parent and child this
is consistent with the theory that the
aliens were invested in manipulating the
lifecycle of the local species to their
ends why though why though why did they
do this why I mean there's a lot of
questions like for research that we
humans do and we're just like I don't
know because we felt like it I don't
know cuz we were bored I don't know
because we want to dabbled with powers
beyond our control you know something
along those lines
man this is just weird all this stuff
alien research equipment hell yeah I
want to know about the probing table
that'd be nice higher to get the data
how about yes you're not okay all right
then I'm onna I'm gonna assume that that
means well
okay these local flora being held in
stasis the aliens evidently saw an
extensive knowledge of the plants
ecosystem a large laboratory table and
accompanying scanners incorporate
technologies far beyond our current
level of understanding hypothesis
equipment maintenance staff maintenance
specimens analysis speed specimen gene
manipulation bodies these aliens sure
did like their genetic manipulation
which is awfully nice of them can they
do some manipulation on me to make me
not so terrified of everything down here
I'd be nice here's a abductee please
mothership oh sorry I always get the
wrong hole if it were oh that guy
definitely who that guys all kinds of
kind of noobs on time so anyway hold on
now that I'm in the experimental mode I
can actually do something that a lot of
people are recommending to me but I
couldn't do which would scan myself the
bacterial infection in your system has
progressed detecting skin irritation and
immune system response so the data
required to identify bacterial strain
okay so if I take my glove off now what
am I gonna see what bumped up against me
yeah nothing so far I am infected though
so that's good to know
great I'm super in fact 'add goobidy
goobidy do but anyway we found that so
unlike what I assumed we did not get
another key but now that we're in the
experimental mode we should see a lot
more changes progressing more quickly as
we go down into the deep alright so we
finally found that and we discovered
some interesting things about these
creatures and this is indeed a
prehistoric remnant of the Leviathan
species I'm really happy
I can't raise an organic composite I'm
really happy that those big ones aren't
around anymore but knowing the
precursors were they trying to resurrect
that lost species for their own ends
were they trying to use something about
them to benefit their species in general
and it's weird that they would
considering the precursors are such an
obviously technologically advanced
species why would they need to they're
able to genetically manipulate pretty
much anything including their own
species so why would they need but sadly
I am actually all out of time and taking
a big dip over here I know it seems like
I'm just not showing you guys everything
that I intend to but I've made a promise
that I was going to go through this this
time I was playing through again calmly
and collectively and we keep discovering
amazing new things and I loved every
second of that because every single time
I go into this game I'm surprised every
single thing I meet I'm surprised and I
love that feeling of surprise I do I
love it I love knowing that around every
single corner is something new and
horrifying that I haven't discovered yet
and yet I keep plowing forward to spite
my brain telling me not to so it's still
fun and I hope you guys are enjoying it
too I'll get that back down to the
inactive lava zone and hopefully the
kyanite will actually work and then I
can utilize that in addition to the
other materials that are down there to
hopefully upgrade my my mr. Pfister
who's going to take you down to the very
deepest part in active
get there soon so thank you everybody so
much for watching as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]